♪ ♪
SPEED TO ONE OF THE
>> Juan: ONE OF THE MOST POWERFU
WILL GO TO PRISON, GUILTY OF
THIRD DEGREE WILL
ACQUITTED HIM OFTHE MOST SERIOUS
A SEXUAL PREDATOR, WHICH
WOULD’VE CARRIED A POTENTIAL
LIFE SENTENCE.
WEINSTEIN FACES UP TO 29 YEARS
IN PRISON.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE FACTS OF
THIS, I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
WITHOUT ROAD AND
RONAN FARROW, WEHAVE THIS TODAY?
MY POINT WAS NBC WAS SITTING ON
THIS, ON THE RONAN FARROW STUFF,
YES?
>> Dagen: IS, AND THEN NBC
TRIED TO GET
DID ALL THE THINGS, LIKE HAVE
THEM FOLLOW PRETTY NASTY THINGS.
RONAN FARROW SAID HE DOESN’T
DESERVE ANY CREDIT,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTERS
WERE THERE, BUT HE ALSO SAID THE
WOMAN WHO CAME FORWARD TO TELL
THE STORIES WERE QUITE
COURAGEOUS.
THEY ASKED FOR A HOME DETENTION
FOR HIM BECAUSE HE HAD THE BACK
SURGERY THAT DIDN’T GO WELL?
LOOKS LIKE IT’S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
HE’S GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO
RIKERS.
HE STILL FACES INDICTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN IF HE WERE
TO MAKE A PLEA DEAL DOWN ON
THOSE, THE JAIL TIME THAT HE
WOULD DO HERE COME OF THAT
CALIBER YOU HAVE WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO.
HE’S FACING 5-29 YEARS ALL THESE
CONVICTIONS.
HE WAS ACQUITTED ON THE LARGER
CHARGES, WHICH INCLUDED THE
UNCHARGED SEXUAL ABUSE
ALLEGATION.
BECAUSE I WATCHED DANA’S SHOW,
THESE CONVICTIONS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO STAND UP UNDER APPEAL
BECAUSE THERE ARE LARGER
CHARGES.
HE WAS ACQUITTED -- I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT ONE THING.
I HOPE THESE REPORTERS,
EVERYONE, KEEPS DIGGING INTO THE
CIRCLE OF PEOPLE AROUND HARVEY
WEINSTEIN THROUGHOUT HOLLYWOOD,
THROUGHOUT POLITICS, WHO COVERED
THIS UP LITERALLY FOR DECADES.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY WITH IT
BECAUSE PEOPLE YOU THAT YOU AND
HELPED HIM BASICALLY DESTROY
WOMEN’S LIVES AND HELP THEM
CONTINUE TO SEXUALLY ASSAULT
WOMEN YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
YEAR.
OR THEY JUST LOOKED AWAY BECAUSE
HE WAS BENEFITING THEIR CAREERS,
HE WAS BENEFITING THEIR
POCKETBOOKS, THAT INCLUDES A LOT
OF DEMOCRATS.
>> Juan: THIS IS ALL NEW TO US
BECAUSE IT JUST HAPPENED TODAY,
FOLKS.
>> Dagen: 5- 29.
>> Juan: MY THOUGHT WAS IF HE
HAD BEEN CONVICTED OF THAT
PREDATORY SEX CHARGE, HE
WOULD’VE GOTTEN LIFE, NOW PEOPLE
ARE SAYING HE’S GOING TO DIE IN
JAIL, AND IN SOME WAYS HE MIGHT
HAVE GOTTEN OFF LIGHT.
>> Jesse: HE’S STILL FACING
CHARGES IN LOS ANGELES.
I DO NOT THINK THIS IS LIGHT.
THESE PROSECUTORS, WE KNOCKED
PROSECUTORS A LOT, ESPECIALLY
FROM NEW YORK ON THEIR SHOW.
THESE PROSECUTORS DID A REALLY
NICE JOB BECAUSE THE VERY HIGHLY
PAID, TALENTED CRIMINAL DEFENSE
TEAM THAT WEINSTEIN HIRED.
WE KNEW HE WAS DANGLING A LOT OF
CASH IN FRONT OF THE VICTIMS AND
TRYING TO PAY PEOPLE OFTEN
HAVING PEOPLE COME AS A CREDIT
TO THEM.
YOU KNOW, THE #MeToo MOVEMENT,
A LOT OF PROBLEMS THERE, FAKE
ALLEGATIONS, NOBODY KNOWS WHAT’S
GOING ON, BUT THIS IS WHERE
THINGS OUGHT TO BE SETTLED.
DUE PROCESS, PEOPLE TESTIFYING,
YOU HAVE EVIDENCE, THEY DECIDE
HOW LONG THEY SHOULD SERVE IT.
THAT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
HERE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE’S BEEN
CONVICTED, GREG.
IN A COURT OF LAW, HE’S A RAPIST
RAPIST.
>> Greg: IT’S A SHAME HILLARY
DIDN’T WIN, BECAUSE SHE COULD’VE
PARTED HIM.
WHY WAS HE SO POWERFUL?
AND USED EMPOWERMENT AS A
LIBERAL VIRTUE SICK NEW
SIGNAL AS A WAYTO PROTECT HIS OW
PEOPLE JOKED ABOUT IT, BUT
BECAUSE HE HELPED THE HOLLYWOOD
ISSUES, HE ACTUALLY ACCUSED
BERNIE SANDERS OF BEING A SEXIST
ALL "MORNING JOE."
MICHELLE OBAMA PRAISED HIM
BECAUSE HE GAVE SO MUCH MONEY.
NO ONE IN THE HOLLYWOOD COULD
NEVER LECTURE US AGAIN ABOUT
MORALITY BECAUSE THEY KNEW ALL
OF THIS.
HE POKED ALL THE RIGHT BUTTONS.
>> Juan: THAT’S A POWERFUL
PEOPLE DO.
THEY GET AWAY WITH A LOT OF
NONSENSE.
ANOTHER BIG CRIME STORY WE ARE
FOLLOWING TODAY, JUST EAST
MILLETT BACK IN COURT
, THE ACTOR PLEADING NOT GUILTY
OF A NEW SET OF CHARGES BEING
ATTACKED BY SUPPORTERS IN THE
ALLEGED HATE CRIME.
I HATE SWISHING THESE TWO GO
TOGETHER.
I KNOW THEY ARE BOTH ANTI-TRUMP
PEOPLE.
>> Dana: WHAT IS UNDER
INDICTMENT
>> Greg: WHAT KEEPS IT
TOGETHER IS THEY BOTH PORTRAY
THEMSELVES AS CHAMPIONS OF THE
AGGRIEVED.
LOOK AT ALL THE PEOPLE FALLING
APART.
JUSSIEJUSTICE MAMA I’M A
VICTIM.
WEINSTEIN GLOMMED ON TO THESE
ISSUES.
THEY ARE ALL IN THE SAME
UNIVERSE OF PRETENDING TO BE FOR
THE COMMON MAN OR THE COMMON
WOMEN SO THEY CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE SITUATION.
>> Juan: THEY NEED TO MAKE AN
EXAMPLE.
YOU CAN’T LIE TO THE POLICE.
IF YOU ARE FAMOUS, LOOK OUT.
LOOK AT MARTHA STEWART.
SHE WENT TO JAIL FOR FIVE MONTHS
FOR OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND
LYING TO THE FBI.
PROCESS CRIME IT MAY BE, BUT
BOOM, WHERE YOU GO
AWAY YOU GO.
>> Juan: WE CAN TALK SOME OF
THOSE OTHER PEOPLE LIKE MIKE
FLYNN AND ROGER STONE...
>> Dana: HE PLED GUILTY, OKAY?
THERE IS THAT.
BUT WITH SMOLLETT, CHICAGO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT WAS WHEN
WHO SAID THAT HE NEEDS TO FACE
THE CHARGES, NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
HOW NICE THIS IS FOR KIM FOX WHO
WAS A STATE ATTORNEY THERE IN
COOK COUNTY, SHE’S BEEN
QUESTION.
HOW COULD YOU LET THIS HAPPEN?
THIS SPECIAL DEAL AND NOTHING WE
HAVE THIS BIG MESS AND IT’S
CONVENIENT BECAUSE SHE SAYS, NOW
THAT HE’S BEEN CHARGED, I CAN’T
COMMENT BECAUSE IT’S UNDER
INDICTMENT.
>> Juan: SHOULD HAVE DONE